PROFESSOR: All right,
let's get started.
So today we're continuing
the theme of locked linkages.
Last time we talked about the
Carpenter's Rule Theorem, which
brought together all of the
rigidity theory and tensegrity
theory we had
built, essentially,
and showed that there
were no locked 2D
chains, paths or
cycles, as graphs.
And in general you can think
in 2D, you can think in 3D,
and you can think
in 4D and higher.
I drew this table way at
the beginning of class.
And you can think
about chains, which
are-- these are so-called open
chains, like robotic arms.
Paths is a graph.
And polygons are closed chains.
And then another case it's
interesting to think about,
and there's been a lot of
work on, are trees where
you don't have any
cycles in your graph,
but you could have branching
points with degree more than 2.
You may recall Carpenter's
Rule Theorem worked whenever
you had a graph of
maximum degree 2.
So it allowed even
multiple chains
in one graph that
could be disconnected.
But it forbade any kind
of tree branching stuff.
So Carpenter's Rule
Theorem is that there's
no locked chains in 2D.
So we did that.
But trees, there are
locked trees in 2D.
3D there are locked chains.
And these are two
results that we
will talk about in
today's lecture.
And that implies that there are
locked trees, sort of obvious.
Trees are more general
than open chains.
And because there's a
locked open chain in 3D,
there's also a locked tree.
In 4D, though, it switches.
So none of these
things are locked.
Of course, there are
locked graphs in general.
But if you look at trees, or
paths, or cycles, none of them
can lock.
We won't have time to talk
about that today, maybe
another class.
Essentially we're
always thinking
about an intrinsically
one dimensional structure.
These edges, bars, are
always one dimensional.
In 2D, where the
space are living in,
the ambient dimension is just
one more than the dimension
of your edges, it's
really interesting.
And that's what
we saw for chains
and what we'll see for trees.
In 3D it gets tricky.
This mismatch of
two in dimension
allows you to lock things,
kind of like knots.
And in 4D there's such--
there's so much freedom
in the way you move,
somehow, nothing
can lock, in the same way
that there are no knots in 4D.
Cool.
So that's the reminder
summary about locked linkages,
what they are, and
what's known about them.
Now we've seen that
chains aren't locked.
But before I get trees I
want to talk about algorithms
for actually doing this.
This is, after all,
geometric folding algorithms.
We've seen a proof
that they exist,
that in fact if we
had a chain, there's
an expansive motion
increases all the distances
and therefore doesn't
collide with itself,
and eventually straightens
all the outermost open chains
and convexifies all the closed
chains that are outermost,
not containing anything.
But how do we actually
find such a motion?
And this has been the
subject of some study.
There are three
algorithms for doing it.
So we'll call this
unfolding 2D chains,
unfolding being the goal of
straightening or convexifying.
And the first algorithm is just
to mimic the proof that we saw.
I call that proof CDR, because
it's Connelly-Demain-Rote.
And if you think
about what we proved,
we just looked at the sort
of infinitesimal case.
We said, if we're at some
position then at least,
for an infinitesimal
amount of time,
we can increase
all the distances.
All the struts can
increase in length,
and the bars stay
the same length.
That's really only specifying
the first derivative
of a motion.
So if you think of motion
as being, I don't know,
some configuration C
that's a function of time,
and you take the derivative
with respect to t,
then we computed what
that derivative should be.
That was the first order motion.
I think we called it d,
which is a little confusing.
This is the d that we computed.
And we said, well that's
an infinitesimal motion
of some tensegrity.
We can find it with
linear programming.
So at any moment in
time we can figure out
what our derivative should be.
This is what's called an
ordinary differential equation,
for those who have
taking 1803 or whatever.
You just solve it.
And a very easy
way to solve it is
if you imagine configuration
space, you start somewhere,
you compute which
way to go, you move
a little bit in that direction.
You're only supposed to go
for an infinitesimal amount.
But it goes some
positive epsilon.
Then recompute
your new direction,
follow that, recompute
follow that for a little
bit, and keep going.
And you're almost tracking
the intended curve.
It's not quite perfect.
But as your step
size, this epsilon,
goes to 0 you approximate
the intended path.
And that's, I mean how
close you approximate
is computed in the textbook.
You can see that for details.
This is a method
called forward Euler.
It's like the simplest way to
solve an ordinary differential
equation.
There are much better ways.
But it's easiest to think
about, and reason about.
And so it gives you some
approximate solution.
Let me show it to you.
I'm going to show
you three methods.
The top one is the
one I'm talking about.
So we're starting
with the same polygon
on the left, simple
little v shape.
A second method is called
pseudo-triangulation.
We'll talk about that next.
The third method's
called energy.
That one's one you've seen.
Let's start with
the first method,
where we take some example
like this teeth example,
and we, at each
step, compute what
is the, in some
sense, the biggest
expanse of motion you could do.
We go a little bit
in that direction.
So in these animations,
the edge links
are changing a little bit.
And I've chosen the step size
so the edge lengths change
by, at most, 10%,
something like that.
And here, this one,
left side we're
zooming, right side
we're not zooming.
These are somewhat
older animations.
So apologies for the frame rate.
What else do I want to say?
This is an example--
well, notice
it's pulling the teeth
off sort of from the end.
If you want to be expensive you
cannot pull the teeth apart.
We're going to see other ways
to do the teeth in a moment.
Here's another example.
Both of these
examples at some point
we're conjectured to be locked.
Before the Carpenter's
Rule Theorem was proved,
a lot of people were trying
to find counter examples.
There aren't any.
So this is nice.
It preserve five-fold
rotational symmetry.
And you can do it for
multiple shapes as well.
So here we have one polygon
in the center, four arcs,
four paths on the outside.
In this case, the simulation
stopped when one of them
convexified because I didn't
implement all of the algorithm.
At that point you just have
to rigidify that polygon
and expand the rest.
So that gives you an
idea sort of visually
what this looks like.
Qualitatively, we can say
a bunch of cool things
about this method.
One is that's it's the
only method that's strictly
expansive, strictly meaning not
only do the struts not decrease
in length, but they
also don't stay the same
whenever that's possible.
They strictly increase.
Now, there are some exceptions.
If I have a bar, obviously,
if I add a strut here
it's not going to strictly
increase in length.
Also, if I have a bunch
of bars that are collinear
and I add a strut
from here to here,
that's not going to
increase in length.
It's not possible.
But all other struts will
strictly increase in length.
You can check.
That's what we proved here.
So that's nice.
Another fun fact, I
didn't write it here,
but it preserves symmetry
if you do it right.
You may notice in
this example actually,
it was originally four-fold
rotationally symmetric.
It does rotate a little bit.
That's from computational error.
And you could correct for that.
I didn't correct for it.
It should, in theory, preserve
the four-fold symmetry there.
Good.
We can compute one step.
So how fast can you
compute this thing?
We can compute one step
in polynomial time.
That's finding an infinitesimal
motion of a tensegrity.
That's linear programming.
But how many steps does it make?
We don't really know.
There is a bound
in the textbook.
It's not very small.
It's also-- with forward Euler
you lose a bit of accuracy.
Now you could
correct for accuracy,
force all the edge
lengths to be the same,
then you won't
preserve the symmetry.
There's a bit of trade off here.
I don't want to spend
too much time on it.
This is the first algorithm.
Although it's the only one
that's strictly expensive,
to me it's not the nicest.
So I'm going to move on
to the next method which
is pointed
pseudo-triangulations.
This is a method
by Ileana Streinu,
basically at the same
time as the original
Carpenter's Rule Theorem.
And these are
examples of what are
called pointed
pseudo-triangulations
for a given set of points.
So in general, a
pseudo-triangle is a polygon
that has three convex vertices.
So a triangle has three
convex vertices and that's it.
A pseudo-triangle, I allow
a bunch of reflex vertices
in between those guys.
So this should be a polygon.
I've drawn it curved.
And if you check in this
figure, all of the faces
are pseudo-triangles.
Most of them here are
actually quadrilaterals.
But in particular,
that's a pseudo-triangle.
Sometimes there's
actual triangles.
Here they're all
quads or triangles.
And a pointed
pseudo-triangulation
has the property
that at every vertex
all of the edges incident
to it lie in a half plane.
They all lie on that side.
In other words, there's an angle
that's bigger than 180 degrees.
So this was a pseudo-triangle,
and this is pointed.
And if you check this
example, every vertex
has an angle that's
bigger than 180 degrees.
Obviously the ones on
the outside have to.
They're always convex.
And pointed
pseudo-triangulations
are-- they're not only supposed
to have these two properties,
but you're also supposed to
have as many edges as possible,
subject to having
these two properties.
If you tried to add any edge
to either of these examples,
you would violate
the pointed property.
If I added this edge, then I'd
destroy this 180 degree angle.
Any edge you
consider, either you
get a crossing--
which is not allowed--
or one of the vertices
loses a 180 degree angle.
So this is actually a
really powerful concept.
And it was introduced by this
paper by Streinu in 2000.
It has lots of theory
built around it by now.
I'm not going to talk
about that theory.
I want to talk about how it
applies to Carpenter's Rule
problem.
I guess the first
thing to say is
that if you have,
say, a polygon-- maybe
I should do a real example,
so I'll make it not so giant.
OK, you take a polygon.
So far it's pointed, right?
Every vertex-- one
of the two sides
has an angle bigger than 180.
So just add as many edges as you
can while still being pointed.
Do, do, do.
This one, that looks OK.
I think that's it.
I think this is a
pseudo-triangulation.
I've added as many edges as I
can while still being point.
It turns out if you start
with something that's pointed,
you'll be able to keep adding
edges, keep it pointed.
And in the end all of the
faces will be pseudo-triangles.
So mission accomplished.
This is a pointed
pseudo-triangulation
that contains, as a subgraph,
my original polygon.
So these are the edge
lengths I want to preserve.
Those should stay rigid.
I'm going to be kind of
crazy and also preserve
the lengths of all
of these edges.
Now if you did that, this
thing would be rigid,
which is not so exciting.
All you need to do to fix that
is remove one of these added
edges that's on the convex hull
on the outer boundary here.
Then it will have one
degree of freedom.
So there will be
two ways to move it.
One is to expand this distance,
the other is to contract it.
And the one that
expands that distance
will expand all distances.
So if you look at some
other pair, like this guy,
every other pair of distances
will expand or stay the same.
So this thing is expansive.
But not strictly
expensive, because we're
preserving these lengths.
These ones will stay the same.
So let me show you some of
the things that can happen.
So this is sort of at the
heart of the algorithm.
I'm not going to go
into all the details.
This can happen like n
cubed times, where you say,
OK I've added in
all these edges.
Here's a nice
pseudo-triangle here.
It happens to be a triangle with
some stuff on the bottom, stuff
on the top.
As I flex this to
expand the distances
this is going to move like that.
At some point,
those three points
will become collinear,
got to deal with that.
And the way you deal with it
is as you continue moving,
it's no longer the case
that those two blue edges
are the edges in the
pseudo-triangulation.
Now it's this one red edge.
This is called a flip.
And you see, we used
to have a quadrilateral
up here an a triangle down here.
Now we have a triangle up here
and a quadrilateral over here.
That's pretty intuitive.
You preserve that it's
a pseudo-triangulation
as you move this.
If you tried to go
too far here you
would actually get a
convex quadrilateral.
If this kept going
then this would
be a convex quadrilateral.
That's not a
pseudo-triangulation,
that's bad.
But you can always
do these flips
to fix it as you go along.
And it turns out
this will only happen
a polynomial number of times.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Like shown,
is how I flipped it.
AUDIENCE: Is it
[INAUDIBLE] to a red?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the red edge
now goes from here to there.
Whereas before there
were two segments that
went from here to
there, now I'm going
to go straight from
there to there.
That's the difference.
This is the general picture,
you have to believe me,
because I want to talk
about other things.
And, cool.
So here's an example
of it actually running.
So we have some polygon
in the top left.
We've deleted the
edge that's cyan.
So that one's going to expand.
And we move a little bit.
This is moving a little bit.
This is moving a
little bit more.
At this point, these three
points are collinear.
Actually, the way it's drawn
it looks like a little bit
too far.
But they should be collinear.
That would be a
violation, because this
would be-- if we go
any farther-- that
would be a violation because
this would be a convex
quadrilateral.
So we do a flip here, and we
end up with that edge instead.
So now everything's
a pseudo-triangle,
everything's pointed,
everything's happy.
You keep going, then these
three points become collinear.
So you end up getting that edge.
And you keep going.
And all throughout this
motion all pairwise distances
are not decreasing.
Everything's expanding
or staying the same.
And then the wrap
up looks like this.
In the end, you get
a convex polygon.
Then you're stuck,
because there's
no edge to remove
on the outside.
You've got to keep
all of those edges.
So that is the
pseudo-triangulation method
in a nutshell.
And it's expansive.
It has a polynomial
in n number of moves.
It's not clear how quickly
you can compute the moves.
I know an exponential
time algorithm.
There might be faster one.
I don't think this
has been resolved.
Let me just check my notes here.
It says best algorithm
is exponential to compute
one move.
In these examples,
where they're all
quadrilaterals or
triangles, it's
really easy to compute them.
In general, if you get
complicated things,
it's unclear.
Pseudo-triangulations though
have a lot of nice structure.
So maybe it's easier than
general linkage folding.
This, I have here,
implementing this algorithm
would be a cool project.
Oh, another open problem
is how many steps
does this algorithm really need?
Can you prove a
pseudo-polynomial bound?
I'm not sure.
But let me tell you about my
personal favorite algorithm,
the energy method.
This is also the
most recent, in 2004.
The weird thing
about this algorithm
is that it is not expansive.
It's really easy to compute
one step of the algorithm.
I can do it in quadratic
time, even exactly.
This one you have to specify
some error tolerance epsilon.
Here you can do it perfectly
if you have exact square roots.
And the number of
steps is also small.
It has a pseudo-polynomial
number of steps.
Have I talked about
pseudo-polynomial yet?
Maybe, briefly at some point.
Let me tell you what I mean.
I want to be polynomial
in the number vertices
n and another parameter r.
r is going to be, basically,
the maximum distance
in your initial
configuration divided
by the minimum distance.
Exactly how you define
distance, don't worry about it.
Not a big deal.
So this is a geometric
feature of the input.
It has nothing to do with n.
n could stay fixed
and you could change
this to whatever
you want by making
nastier and nastier examples.
Nastiness is measured here by
how big your linkages versus
how tight things get.
So as long as that's
reasonable, this
is going to be a
polynomial number of moves.
So this is a good bound.
It's better than all the others
that's been proved anyway.
It might hold for some
of the other methods.
Here, of course, we have a
better bound on the number
moves.
But each move is
kind of complicated.
It's pseudo-triangulation.
So there is a trade
off between complexity
of move and number of moves.
But this gets a decent
bound for everything.
You've seen this method.
I showed it in lecture one.
But it's interesting to contrast
it with the CDR method, which
sort of unrolled the
teeth from the end.
Here, this method basically
pulls the teeth right apart.
And that's possible because it's
not required to be expansive.
And we have the double tree.
This one looks more
or less the same.
It's a little smoother, I would
say, than the other method.
I don't have it side by side.
So it's a little hard to guess.
And what's really exciting
about this method, to me,
is that you can run it
for really large examples
in like a minute or so.
500 vertices, no big deal.
Whereas, because each
step is pretty easy
to compute in quadratic
time, with this method
you need it to solve
a convex program.
And that's a little
costly for large examples.
Cool.
So that's the energy method.
Now I'm going to actually
tell you how it works.
Big difference is
it's not expansive.
And the idea is,
well, being expansive
on every edge,
that's kind of hard.
How do I figure that out?
Oh, it makes my brain hurt.
I've got to solve
this tensegrity.
But if I was just
expansive on average,
maybe that would be good enough.
That's the crazy idea.
So we define this energy
function that does just that.
It's a function
on configurations.
So I'm going to write E of
C. No M in this equation.
We're going to sum over all
edges Ew, and then sum over all
vertices U different
from V and W.
And we're going to take 1
over the distance from U
to the edge.
This is just saying sum over
all non-incident vertices
and edges, take their
distance-- there's
many ways you could define
that, like the minimum distance
between them would be
fine-- take the reciprocal,
add them all up.
This is my energy function.
Kind of weird.
But it's averaging
not of distances,
but 1 over distances.
So why is that so interesting?
Because distances
are always positive.
So I only have to go over here.
If I write distance
in the x-axis,
and 1 over the
distance in the y-axis,
the plot of that
function looks like this.
It has this vertical
asymptote at 0.
So if the distance were to
go to 0, which is bad for me
because that's one thing start
crossing-- they will start
touching at d equals 0, and
after that they might cross--
the energy shoots to
positive infinity.
So if I take the sum over all
these, if any of the distances
decrease to 0 then the energy
will shoot to infinity.
What if my distances increase?
Because I know
expansive motions exist.
That's what we proved last time.
I'm not going to compute them.
But I know they're
out there somewhere.
If I had an expansive motion,
all of these distances
increase.
So that means this
reciprocal decreases.
So I have-- it's
hard to imagine--
I have this giant dimensional
configuration space.
It has d times n
dimensions, whatever.
A lot of stuff.
I'm somewhere.
But if I now plotted--
imagine that's
in two dimensions,
in the plane here,
so that's there-- and then
in the third dimension I
plot what is this
energy landscape.
For each of these configurations
I compute some height.
What is my energy?
I get some 3D surface here.
In general, it's going to be
d times n plus 1 dimensions.
Here's the configuration space.
We plot over that.
What I'm saying is, because
expansive motions exist,
there has to be a motion
for every point that
decreases energy.
Because if you decrease
every distance,
you also decrease them
on average in this sense.
If every term decreases,
then of course, the sum will.
So this means energy
decreasing motions exist.
Now energy decreasing
feels like a good thing.
Because I start somewhere, it
has some energy, not infinity.
If I decrease the energy,
it's really hard for my energy
to go to plus infinity.
It can't happen.
So all I need to do is follow
any energy decreasing motion.
It might be an expansive
one, but probably not.
We know that there are
energy decreasing motions
because there are
expansive motions.
But let's just take
any energy decreasing
motion, sort of
expansive on average.
Then it won't self-intersect
because if energy decreases
it will never get
to plus infinity.
And therefore none of the
distances will go to 0.
So what this algorithm does
is follow the gradient.
So I should say something
about what this notation is.
This is whatever,
higher order calculus.
You live in some space.
You're on like some
hill, or whatever.
You're on some surface.
And you say well I'd really
like to go downhill from here.
And there might be
many downhill options.
There might be many
uphill options.
This is some crazy high
dimensional choice.
Just take the option
that decreases energy
the fastest, the most downhill.
That is negative gradient of
E. Believe me that it exists.
It exists because this
energy function is smooth,
in some sense.
You're basically taking
first derivatives.
That gives you the
highest chain--
or you take the place that has
the highest change and boom.
That gives it to you.
It's very easy to compute
because this function has
quadratically many terms.
It takes about n
squared time to find it.
And that gives you some
energy decrease in motion.
It's just an easy one to find.
And that's what we're
animating all the time.
So we just find energy
decreasing motion,
move a little bit
in that direction.
Not too much,
because if you go--
it's again a first derivative.
This is only an
infinitesimal motion.
But we're actually going
to move in that direction
for a positive amount of time.
As long as we don't go too
far, and we can find how
far by binary search,
we won't self-intersect.
Because we know locally
it's decreasing energy.
If we go small enough step it
really will decrease energy,
and then life is good.
So it's really easy to do this.
Super simple algorithm.
Good.
It's non-expansive
because we're only
decreasing the average,
not each of the terms.
Do, do, do, do, do.
You can prove the
number of steps--
this is the part I'm most proud
of here-- is pseudo-polynomial,
polynomial in n and r.
What is the polynomial?
n to the 123 times r to the 81.
This is the largest
polynomial bound
I know of that's not
dependent on dimension.
So I'm very proud.
In practice, the number of
steps is much, much smaller
than this.
This is what we could
prove in an easy way.
If you want a project,
it's a little tedious,
but it would be easy,
I'm pretty sure.
You could decrease
this to, I don't know,
at least n to the
20 or something
by being a little more
careful on the analysis.
But once we got something
that was pseudo-polynomial
we were happy.
So we could leave others to
figure out the right bound.
It's a little tricky with these
gradient descent algorithms
to get good bounds.
In practice they
work really well,
because the gradient
is not as nasty
as you might imagine it
to be in the worst case.
But the worst case bound,
hey, it's pseudo-polynomial.
It's a nice
theoretical guarantee.
And in practice it
also happens to work.
Like these examples
only take, I don't know,
a few hundred steps,
1,000 steps, whatever.
AUDIENCE: Where do
those numbers come from?
PROFESSOR: Where
does 123 come from?
We really wanted
it to be 1, 2, 3.
81 is my birth year.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: That's why I
like this number so much.
Oh, actually here
I have 41 written.
I'm pretty sure it's 81 though.
I should correct the notes,
double check, something.
It's really you're just adding
up twos and threes a lot,
and fours, and things like
that a whole bunch of times.
And then just luckily it
came out to a nice number.
As far as I know,
not intentional.
There are few authors
though, so I don't know.
Maybe one of them increased
a bound to make it a little
cooler number in the end.
Good.
So that's pseudo-polynomial
number of steps.
It's interesting,
each of the steps
is actually a very nice motion.
It just moves along
a straight line
in the configuration space.
I would be nice to know
whether you can actually
achieve a polynomial number
of steps independent of r.
I think the answer
is no, it's not
possible for some linkages
that are really tight.
I think you need a dependence,
a polynomial dependence,
on r-- at least a
linear dependence on r.
But I don't know
how to prove that.
It's a nice open problem.
Another fun problem, these
examples with polygons
end up with a particular
convex shape in the end.
Is that shape unique?
If I gave you the sequence
of edge lengths here,
they're all 1, or
they're almost 1.
Not quite the same.
No, sorry, they get tinier
as you go to the center.
But for that sequence
of edge lengths,
is there a unique minimum
energy configuration?
I think so.
But I don't know.
We know that this method
will get to convex,
because only at the
convex configuration
do you no longer have
an expansive motion
and no longer have a decreasing
energy motion, maybe.
Cool.
Those are the three algorithms.
Any questions about them?
Before we go to trees, again,
tell you a cool application
to origami, which
is to rigid origami.
Remember, rigid origami, we're
not allowed to add any creases.
And all of the faces between
creases have to stay flat.
They're like made
of-- imagine you
have pieces of metal
representing the faces.
You have piano hinges
making the edges.
That's rigid origami.
That's kind of like a linkage.
In particular, when you
have a single vertex
origami-- say that's five
foldable, I don't know.
And if you say each
of these wedges
is a rigid piece of
metal, well we already
know this kind of set up can
be modeled by its boundary.
Ignore the interior.
Just think of there
being hinges of this one
dimensional structure like that.
So that looks a
lot like a linkage.
These have to stay rigid.
They're not straight lines.
It's a little different.
It's almost the same.
If you think about how you're
allowed to fold these things--
really you should
think about it here,
I guess-- what happens, by
a continuous motion what
happens is that you're
living on a sphere.
So you start out on the
equator of the sphere.
This thing, just plop
it down the equator.
The boundary lies on the
boundary of the sphere.
The interior of the paper
is inside the sphere,
right along the flat part there.
As you fold, these points
will stay on the sphere.
And these edge links
will be preserved,
their arcs on the spheres.
There will be great
circular arcs at all times.
So folding this
thing in three space
is really equivalent to folding
this linkage on the sphere.
And that looks an awful lot
like a polygon on a sphere.
What we really want is a
spherical Carpenter's Rule
Theorem.
And there is.
This is by Streinu and Whiteley.
So if you have a closed chain,
a polygon, of total length
at most 2 pi on a
unit sphere then you
have a connected
configuration space.
So in the plane,
closed chain always
had a connected
configuration space.
On the sphere you need that
the chain is not too long,
because there's only sort
of a bounded amount of room
on the sphere.
The equator has total length 2
pi, perimeter of the equator.
For unit sphere it's 2 pi.
So we're just canonically
making it a unit sphere.
And 2 pi really corresponds
to this situation,
which is 360 degrees.
That's how much
total length we have.
So it just fits in the
equator, life is good.
The reason you want
it to have length
at most 2 pi is because
then you actually do
have a convex configuration.
In the case of 2 pi, it
lies along the equator.
If it's smaller than 2 pi it'll
be like some smaller portion.
This would be less than
2 pi on the sphere.
If it's greater than 2 pi,
you can't draw it convexly
on the sphere.
You can draw something.
Like I could draw
something like this,
that'll have really long
length on the sphere.
But there will be no
way to convexify it.
You get stuck at some point.
And as long as you don't
have that situation,
you can take this--
what this actually
implies is that your
polygon at all times
will lie in a hemisphere.
You take that hemisphere
and you sort of unroll it,
you splay it out, you
project it to the plane.
You apply the planar
Carpenter's Rule Theorem.
You apply the fact that
unrolling operation,
or that projection
if you will-- I
think it's like
projection from some point
here out to the plane--
that projection preserves
infinitesimal flexibility
of tensegrities.
So it'll still have the
expensive motion in the plane.
And then you could turn in to an
expansive motion on the sphere.
And eventually you'll
get a convex polygon.
So that's sort of
how this is proved.
Then you can apply
it to rigid origami,
and say for single
vertex origami,
it's always rigidly foldable.
Any state you want
to reach can be
reached by continuous
motion, without bending
any of the faces.
So a fun little application.
And one of the few things
we know about rigid origami,
for multiple vertices
it gets a lot harder.
Not always possible,
and we don't
have a nice characterization.
So finally, let's move onto
locked trees in the plane.
So these are sort of
the classic examples.
The top two were
in a 1998 paper.
This was when I started
working on folding stuff, very
beginning.
A whole bunch of people
from a big workshop.
First example is this one.
And it's a bunch of sort of
arms tucked into their armpits,
and in a cyclic way.
And the dotted circles
mean objects in this mirror
are closer than they appear.
So imagine that
all of these points
are actually really, really
close and tight in here.
And this guy's actually
really close and tight
against this edge.
So I've drawn it
with lots of slack
so you can see the
combinatorial structure.
But geometrically
it's much tighter.
Then the intuition is that you
can't get any of these arms
open unless you could somehow
expand one of these wedges.
It's like, if you could
expand this angle then
this guy would have
room to come out.
But how do I expand that angle?
Well I'd have to compress
the other angles because
of the cyclic picture.
And I can't, if I look at some
other angle like this one,
I can't compress it because
the arm is in the way.
So I can't open an arm until
I've closed some other arm.
And I can't close an arm
before I've opened it.
And so nothing can happen.
That's the intuition
behind the proof.
The details are very
messy, because you
have to define open
and closed, and what
things must happen
before what things.
This example should
look familiar
because if you double it, if
you replace every edge with two
edges, we get one
of the examples that
was expanding with the
five-fold symmetry.
So people have sort
of known for a while,
and then we finally proved,
that this is locked.
If you double it, people thought
well maybe it's still locked.
Turns out no, because the center
vertex can expand in a polygon,
but with a tree it can't.
OK, big deal.
These examples, this is just
yet another way to do that.
But what's interesting is if
you double some of the edges
you get this tree.
So you have 1 degree 3
vertex in the center.
And you go around,
you visit this arm.
You go back, you visit this arm.
Turns out this really
does simulate this tree,
because we haven't touched
the central degree 3 vertex.
And this is nice because
it has one degree 3 vertex.
Everything else
is degree 2 or 1.
So in the Carpenter's
Rule theorem
where we said maximum
degree 2, it's really tight.
And as soon as you add
one vertex of degree 3
you can be locked.
That was the point
of this example.
What other fun things
can you do with trees?
Well, three years
ago in this class
we started thinking
about other locked trees.
How low could you go?
How many edges do
need to get locked?
This example-- no I guess
this example would be minimum.
Here I've drawn it
with eight petals.
You can get away
with five petals,
or are five arms,
each of length 3.
So that's 15 edges.
That was the state of the art.
And then we had this crazy
idea in a problem session
of this locked
chain, locked tree.
It has two degree 3 vertices.
And it kind of just
winds in there.
We're going to see why
these things are locked.
But OK, that's kind of neat.
11, that's much better than 15.
Can we do better?
And every week we improved
it, for a few weeks.
This one looks messier,
but it has one fewer edge.
And then this one came
along, and we're like whoa.
So symmetric, so beautiful.
What's interesting is it doesn't
have the cyclic structure.
It's almost flat, in fact.
You could think of all these
guys being in one point.
All these guys
being in one point.
All those guys
It's like they're,
all three, collinear.
So it's a very different
kind of example.
Before we thought
locked trees required
this kind of cyclic condition.
And so, for example,
we conjectured--
or I guess Poon,
one of the authors
here-- conjectured that
there would be no way
to lock something if
all the edges were
horizontal and vertical.
Because if you have
that you couldn't
have five things in a circle.
Now suddenly we think,
oh, this is interesting.
Because it has two
degree 3 vertices.
It's so symmetric.
Surely this is the
fewest possible edges
we could get away with.
But no, then we found
the eight edge example.
And this is kind of funny.
It's like instead of
being nice and symmetric,
essentially, what we're
doing is removing this edge.
And we want to instead
attach it in here.
But then we have to futz
around with the vertices
to make it work
out and be a tree.
And now has only
one degree 3 vertex.
So it also has
that nice property.
It only has eight edges.
And this, we
believe, is optimal.
And we can actually prove
something along those lines.
So a linear tree is one where
all the vertices lie nearly
on the line.
So this is a linear locked tree.
And we can prove that among
all linear locked trees,
they must have at
least eight edges.
Locked linear tree has
at least eight edges.
So at least among linear locked
trees that example is optimal.
But maybe you could use
the second dimension
to do something better
than eight edges.
But I don't think so.
That's an open problem.
What other good
things can we do?
You can make it orthogonal.
You can mimic exactly
this structure
with an orthogonal
structure, all the edges
horizontal and vertical.
Just expand each of these
vertices into very tiny,
and if this is drawn
really squished,
these are super short edges.
So they really don't change
the motion space hardly at all.
You can actually prove that.
And this is also locked.
That's one of the nice things
you do once you get out
of the cyclic kind of structure.
I think I have
something else, no.
OK, stay there.
Yeah, actually maybe
I do want to go there.
This is an example, it has
a cyclic structure again.
Same paper, last year.
This is a newer example.
And it has the property
that all of the edge lengths
are the same, and
nothing touches.
Now you'll appreciate this in
a little while, how crazy this
is.
Because all of the
previous examples
required things to be
very close and tight.
And we crucially use
very tight proximity
in order to prove
things are locked.
And if you take the example
that looks like this, with six
arms-- I didn't
draw it very well.
But if you draw
it with six arms,
these are like
equilateral triangles,
the edge lengths will
be almost all the same.
In fact, if you
allow them to touch
they will be exactly the same.
So there was this
open question, well,
if I want them to be exactly
the same but not touch,
can you still lock?
We thought no, but in
fact you can do it.
And this is very
tricky to prove locked
because we can't make
these arbitrarily tight.
It really has to look like
this, because the edge lengths
are all the same.
Now this has
seven-fold symmetry.
Because sixfold they
would all touch.
It's tricky.
Cool.
A big open question
here, of course,
is to characterize locked trees.
I think that's quite hard,
because in particular,
if you're given a tree
and you want to know
does that go from
this configuration
to this configuration,
that's known to be p space
complete, which is
really, really hard.
But all of those
examples are locked.
So maybe unlocked trees
have some special structure
that's easy to find.
I guess not.
But who knows?
What I do think has
a nice structure
are these linear locked trees.
They're pretty simple.
They're basically
one dimensional.
And I think we could
characterize linear lock trees
in polynomial time.
Maybe we'll work on
that this afternoon.
But that is open.
All right, next thing
I want to talk about
is how the heck do you prove
that these things are locked?
Now historically there have
been lots of different proofs.
And this tree still does
not have a nice proof
that it's locked.
But all the other trees I
can give you very succinct
proofs that they're locked.
And so I want to tell
you how we do that.
Because it uses tensegrity
theory, our good friend.
This is the idea of
infinitesimally locked
linkages.
So ignore this part of
the picture for now.
If we take some tree,
most of the examples
I drew these little
scion circles to say,
well, these guys
are really tight.
And the intuition
is the tighter you
make it, the less that
configuration can move.
If you look, we're
claiming the configuration
space is disconnected.
But not only that, we
have this configuration
and we say there's a
small ball of motions
that you could possibly do.
It does wiggle a little bit.
And then there's
other stuff over here
that you can never reach because
this can't move very much.
Well in fact, if you make these
circles tighter and tighter,
the claim is that this,
in the space of motions,
you get less and less freedom.
How could we formalize that?
As you draw the thing tighter
you get less and less motion.
Well, let's go to the limit.
Suppose we went all
the way to the point
that these things are touching.
Now this is going to be a
little tricky mathematically,
because we have to remember that
this vertex is in this wedge,
even though it's actually
right on top of this point.
So we have to remember, sort
of, how things look locally.
But geometrically the picture
is going to look like that.
If you look from
afar, you won't be
able to tell that there's
three edges along here,
because they're right
on top of each other.
But if you, sort of, imagine
zooming in infinitesimally
in each of these
vertices, it's going
to be whatever the heck it is.
So you remember the fact
that right here there
are four vertices.
And this is how they're
connected to incident edges.
There's actually three edges
here, and two edges here,
and so on.
So that's how you
describe one of these,
we call them,
self-touching linkages.
Because the edges are
touching each other.
They're right on
top of each other.
Now normally, if you wanted to
capture this notion of wiggling
a little bit, we
could define the idea
of being locked within epsilon.
So a configuration is
locked within epsilon
if it's impossible
to get farther
than epsilon in
configuration space.
So that's this little ball,
thinking about radius epsilon
here.
And if you can't get
outside that ball,
you have some weird
space you can get to.
But if it's bounded by
a ball of radius epsilon
then I say you're
locked within epsilon.
And if epsilon is
small that really
means there are other
things you can't get to.
Well as soon as I
get to self-touching
I can actually think about
being locked within epsilon
for epsilon equals 0,
also known as being rigid.
We've already talked about
being locked within 0.
If you can't move it
all, that's rigid.
So this thing could
actually be rigid.
Whereas all the
locked trees, they
can never be rigid
because I don't
want them to really touch.
This is an analysis tool.
I don't like trees
that are self-touching.
It's kind of ugly and cheating.
And so real trees,
non-self-touching touching
trees could only be locked
within some positive epsilon.
But if we consider
for the moment
the extreme when
they're touching then
we could hope for rigidity.
Rigidity is good because we know
how to prove things are rigid.
We know how to test things
are rigid in two dimensions.
It's pretty easy.
We could test is it
infinitesimally rigid?
If it's infinitesimally
rigid we know it's rigid.
It's a little bit
trickier because we
have to represent the
non-crossing constraints.
And that's what these
purple edges do.
So the idea is,
well I definitely
want to preserve the
lengths of these edges.
I'm not interested
in expansive motions,
because that's a subset
of possible motions.
But I do know that this
vertex should move away
from this edge, or
stay on the edge.
It's not allowed to go to
the other side of the edge.
So I imagine there's a
little tiny strut here.
It's of infinitesimal
length right now.
It can get longer, but it has
to get longer in that direction.
You have to move
away-- you have to stay
on the right side of this edge.
And you have to stay on
the left side of this edge.
It turns out you really can
represent that by a strut.
It's now a strut between
a vertex and an edge,
because this guy can slide along
the edge, or move away from it.
But it's a strut.
And you can think of
this as a tensegrity,
all the usual tensegrity
theory applies.
You can define equilibrium
stresses, polyhedral liftings,
infinitesimal rigidity.
And so what's
actually drawn here--
you should look at the
book for more details.
I don't want to go
into details on this.
But originally the state of
the art for proving something
like this is locked
is you basically
give-- you show an
equilibrium stress that
is positive on all the struts.
We know that if you
find a stress that's
positive on all struts
than all the struts in fact
must act as bars.
What that means is that this
length, which is currently 0,
must stay 0.
Therefore this
vertex is actually
pinned because it has
to both be on this edge
and be on this edge.
That's what a 0 length bar
here and here would mean.
It really has to be right here.
It can't move it all.
And therefore this whole thing
is rigid, and nothing moves.
Clear?
So we can use all
the tensegrity stuff
to prove that when this thing
is actually self-touching,
and all these distances
are 0, it is rigid.
But so what?
Who cares about the
self-touching thing
being rigid?
It's nice, but what
I really care about
is the non-self-touching
configurations
are locked within epsilon,
for some tiny epsilon.
Well good news.
Rigidity of the
self-touching configuration
implies what's called
strongly locked,
yet another term which
I need to define.
Strongly locked means
that sufficiently small,
sufficiently small
perturbations of the linkage,
or I should say of the
linkage configuration,
are locked within
epsilon for any epsilon.
This is exactly the property
I wanted to formalize,
saying that if you draw
the example tighter
it can move less.
For any epsilon, we
want to say you can only
move within epsilon,
there's some notion
of sufficiently small such
that if I take this example
and imagine currently
all the vertices are
on top of each other.
But now I perturb
it a little bit,
which involves changing not
only the vertex coordinates,
but also the edge lengths--
but a tiny amount, some delta
that's a function of epsilon.
Whatever epsilon
you choose, there's
a very small disk I
can draw like this,
such that as long as all the
vertices stay within that disk
your example will be
locked within epsilon.
This is great because it lets
us analyze rigidity, which
is easy for self-touching
configurations, which are not
interesting in some sense.
But we get to conclude something
about the perturbations which
are not self-touching
and therefore nice.
And we get the property
we want, that you're
locked within epsilon
for any epsilon you want.
You just draw it
tighter you'll be
locked within a smaller epsilon.
So this is pretty cool.
And I didn't defined
perturbation.
But I just mean every vertex
stays within a radius delta
disk.
And sufficiently
small here is delta,
which is a function of epsilon.
So this is pretty cool.
And it turns out also--
this is proved much later--
these results are like 2002.
And then 2006 proved
that if you take
any self-touching configuration,
which is like this,
you specify the geometry
where things are all
on top of each other.
And then you'd say what you
want every vertex to look like.
It turns out there really
is a valid perturbation that
preserves that
combinatorial structure
and is arbitrarily small.
So here, of course, I've
drawn it so it's clear.
You can perturb things.
And I changed the edge
lengths a little bit.
But I can actually realize
this combinatorial structure.
It turns out that's
always possible.
So you can take any
self-touching linkage,
you can perturb it so
it's not self-touching,
and it is arbitrarily
locked within epsilon.
And the way you
prove it, or one way
to prove that
something is rigid,
is to say well this
proof is infinitesimally
rigid by constructing an
equilibrium stress that's
positive on all these
0 length struts.
As long as it's positive
all those 0 length
struts you know that
they're effectively bars.
Usually once they're
bars it's really obvious
that the thing is rigid because
it pins vertices into corners.
Then you know that the whole
thing is infinitesimally rigid,
therefore it's rigid,
therefore it's strongly locked.
And you could see some examples
of doing that in the book.
But this is no longer
the state of the art.
There are now
easier ways to prove
that trees are
locked-- some trees.
It doesn't always work.
Of course, it might be
infinitesimally flexible.
Lots of things could fail.
But if it succeeds in
proving something is rigid,
then you know it's strongly
locked and you're happy.
So it's a conservative
test, you might say.
It would be a cool
thing to implement.
This is not hard, it's
just linear programming.
But there's a cooler way
that's even more-- like one
where I can really
draw the pictures here,
you know we had to
draw all these diagrams
and figure out that stress
positive numbers worked on all
these edges, and
eh, it's tedious.
There's a much slicker way.
And for whatever reason, they
have become known as the rules.
There are two of them.
Although we've tried to come
up with various rule threes,
the ones that have been
tried and tested and used
all over the place are
rule one and rule two.
So rule one.
You'll see why this is
interesting in a moment.
I have some linkage,
self-touching linkage.
We're in the same framework.
Suppose these two edges
have the same length.
I'm drawing this
one slightly smaller
just so I can show you,
which is on which side.
But suppose they
have the same length.
And suppose that
both of these angles
are acute, strictly,
less than 90.
What do you think
happens in this picture?
I have this bar floating around.
And I have these three bars.
What happens to this bar?
AUDIENCE: It's confined to
be against the other bar.
PROFESSOR: It's confined to
be right against this edge.
It can't move at all until
this angle-- both of these,
and I guess at least one of
them would have to get to 90,
then you could try
to slide it out.
Like if this one goes beyond
90 then you can slide out.
As long as they're both less
than 90 it's pinned there.
So what I'm going to do
is redraw this diagram as
with two edges there, which
I mean, you can just ignore.
The point is if there's
something attached here
and here-- maybe many things,
it's a tree, who knows?--
you can just attach
them right there.
This is a simplification
to the linkage.
It does not behave the same.
But it has the same rigidity.
Because if all I care
about is rigidity,
I care about can I move at all?
So in order for this
guy to move and all,
these guys would
first have to move
for quite a while, a
positive amount of time.
I just want to know can
I move 0 or more than 0?
If I can move more than 0 I
could move this guy more than 0
without this guy moving at all.
So really I don't care
about how this guy moves.
He's effectively pinned for at
least a small amount of time.
I really care about can
the rest move it all?
So you can simplify
your linkage like this,
and the rigidity
will be preserved.
This is awesome because it's
easy to see when this applies.
And you just
simplify your linkage
until you can just tell
whether it's rigid.
All right rule two is
sort of a special case.
It looks like this.
So here, this bar and this bar
actually share an endpoint.
And again, I need that
this angle is acute.
And I need that these
two have the same length.
And I can simplify
to that, where
if anything was attached here
it just gets attached there.
Let's try it out.
Actually, I could
use some more boards.
So I'm just going to copy the
example we had from before.
And this will work on
basically all the examples
I've shown you except
the equilateral one.
This is the one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight bar example.
This is conjectured minimum.
Let's prove that it's locked.
See any rule one's
we could apply?
Do you see any edges
that are effectively
wedged against another edge?
Remember, all of these
vertices are actually
on top of each
other, we're thinking
about the self-touching version.
These guys are
actually touching,
and these guys are
actually touching.
AUDIENCE: This rule
one [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There's a rule one--
AUDIENCE: That one, there.
PROFESSOR: --here?
Yeah, good.
This edge is pinned
against this edge.
Because look, we have acute
angles here, namely 0.
There's an acute
angle here, that's 0.
And this edge, if these guys
are on top of each other,
and these guys aer
on top of each other,
these two edges have
the same length.
Therefore these are
pinned together.
So let me redraw it when
they're pinned together.
I'm drawing things with curves
just so it's easier to draw,
but you understand this
is also basically flat.
Again these guys are all
on top of each other,
these are on top of each other,
these are on top of each other.
Did I do that right?
I think so, yep.
Anymore?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes,
on the right side.
It's another rule one.
Here it's actually
pretty symmetric.
Is this locked?
Is this rigid?
It's kind of hard to say.
But now it's going
to be pretty obvious.
Because when these
guys join together
that means these
two vertices really
are on top of each
other for positive time.
Same for these.
So a new example looks
like two triangles
with an edge floating there.
Now it's pretty
obvious this is rigid.
But if you really want
to make it obvious
you can apply rule
two to this guy.
And then these guys
are pinned together.
And then you have two triangles.
Two triangles are rigid.
I think that's pretty obvious.
You could check it, whether
they're infinitesimally rigid,
whatever you feel like.
But because that's rigid,
this is rigid, this is rigid,
this is ridged.
Because these operations
preserve rigidity.
They don't preserve
locked or whatever,
but they preserve rigidity.
Once you know that
this is rigid you
know that it's strongly locked.
So when you perturb it
so these guys are not
on top of each other, but
they're slightly spread out,
it will be locked
within epsilon,
for any epsilon you want.
Now this is super easy.
And this is how we
were able to iterate
through all those locked
trees, and say, oh yeah,
this is still rigid, so
it's still strongly locked.
Now this doesn't always work.
But it seems pretty good.
And one of the
conjectures on the tables
is that for linear
trees rules one and two
are kind of almost enough.
It's not literally true.
But it's hopefully mostly true.
AUDIENCE: It seems that
that argument would
mean you wouldn't need
one of the n's on--
PROFESSOR: Right, so we could
think about this example.
And you're asking do you need--
does this need to be that long
or could we throw
away the last bar?
Right, it looks
like that's good.
If you throw away this
bar it's still the case
that this edge you
can apply rule one,
and say that it's pinned
against this edge.
And once those are there,
this thing basically
acts as a single triangle,
and life is good.
Yeah, so you can
remove this one edge.
You could not remove both of
the edges, at least for rule one
to apply, because then this
guy's not wedged into anything.
He's wedged on this side but
he's not wedged on that side.
But you can remove this edge.
And that's a super
easy way to prove
that this thing is locked.
We didn't know this when
we wrote the textbook,
otherwise we would
have given that proof.
There's one based on
stresses in the textbook.
But here, yeah, you can make
very easy judgments like that.
Now it doesn't
mean that it's not
locked when you remove
two of the edges.
I'm not sure, no I
think it's not locked.
But just because the
rules don't apply
doesn't tell you
that's not locked.
But it at least makes
it hard to prove.
And it's a good
sort of guideline.
Questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did the perturbations
that are positive and finite
have numbers?
Like, what's-- it's sort of
disturbing that they get very,
very small-- what are they?
PROFESSOR: So you want
to know how big is delta?
How big is epsilon?
Well it depends, of course, how
much motion you want to allow,
how small the
perturbations have to be.
And I don't have a great answer.
I do recall that we computed
a bound, probably in terms
of something like r, the
maximum distance divided
by the smallest non 0 distance.
So it depends how close to
tight you are in other places.
And it depends on your epsilon.
There is an explicit bound.
I think it's polynomial
on those two things.
But I don't quite remember.
So you can actually compute
how much perturbation
will give you locked
within epsilon.
But it's certainly not clean.
It's actually not too hard
to prove this statement
just using topology.
Should I try to remember
how to prove it?
Basically, yeah, so
there's this fun fact.
Suppose you have
some tensegrity.
So tensegrities
are kind of hard.
They say, look, a bar has
this length, ain't changing.
Let's be a little more flexible.
What if you said, oh, this
bar can change within epsilon?
Because in reality you could
probably pull the metal
a little bit, just
not very much.
Struts, it's not
supposed to get smaller.
Let's say it can get epsilon
smaller than it's supposed to.
It turns out if you take
some tensegrity that's rigid,
and then you add this
little bit of flexibility
so the edges can change
in length a tiny amount,
then before you made this change
your configuration was a point,
and there might have
been other stuff.
But locally you
couldn't move at all.
If you add this
flexibility, the new picture
is a point with a
tiny ball around it.
And whatever, I mean this
might change a little bit also.
But the point is this point
doesn't get much bigger when
you add just a little
bit of flexibility.
This is a fact that was
known in rigidity theory.
It's called sloppy rigidity.
And it's essentially what's
going on here-- that we're
adding a little bit
of perturbation.
Before you couldn't move at all.
Now you can move a little bit.
We just had to generalize
from regular tensegrity
so these weird tensegrities
with sliding struts.
And this is kind of intuitive.
To really check it
you just need to check
that the constraints on edges
and struts are closed sets,
and then the have
to behave this way.
But you can actually compute
how quickly they change.
It's just messy.
So I'll leave it at that.
Hey, there's a little
proof addition,
glad I still remember it.
Other questions?
This is the end of 2D trees.
And now I want to talk
briefly about 3D chains.
So we did this one, now
I want to do this one.
Actually this is one of the
oldest results, from 1998.
So right around the same
time as the locked trees.
I may have shown this example
last time, or in lecture one.
But here it is again.
Three bars in the
center, and two
really long bars in the ends.
We call this knitting needles,
because it's like two knitting
needles with a short
string connecting them,
tied in a knot, sort of.
Topologically this
is not knotted.
If you could add
extra creases here
you could pull that
through, no problem.
But if this is rigid,
like a linkage,
then this thing
is locked provided
each end bar has
length strictly greater
than the sum of the middle bars.
So there's three middle bars
here, add up their lengths,
it should be shorter
than this one
and it should be
shorter than this one.
That's the cutoff.
And I believe once it's
the other way around,
this is not locked.
Sadly, rules one and do not
prove this thing is locked.
They only work in
two dimensions.
But for this one example--
and to tell you the truth,
this is pretty much the only
example of a locked open chain
that we have-- there's a
really simple, nice proof.
Let me draw the picture again.
AUDIENCE: Do you
need the bottom one?
PROFESSOR: You're asking do I
need three bars in the center,
or could I get away with two?
In fact, to draw this in
3D you need three bars.
That's maybe not obvious.
But if you tried to draw
it would just four bars,
like this, it's
not really possible
because these three
points are coplanar,
as all three points
are, and then yeah.
You can't get this
weaving pattern.
This guy's going to be either
above or below the plane.
And this guy's going to be
And in all cases, you
don't get this weaving.
So you really need the five.
This is the minimum.
You can prove all four
bar 3D chains to not lock.
But with five you can do it.
Good question.
So here's how we're
going to prove
that this thing is locked.
So there are these three edges,
they have various lengths,
who knows?
But add up the lengths, divide
by 2, and measure out that far.
So I'm going to call that
the midpoint of those three
segments.
I want to center a ball here.
It's going to look
something like that.
It's a 3D ball centered there.
So it's a ball, diameter equal
to the sum of the middle bars.
So radius is half that.
And the center is the midpoint
of the sum of the middle bars,
whatever.
So the radius is half the
sum of the middle bars.
And this is at half the
Therefore these middle
bars stay inside the ball.
Maybe they touch the boundary.
But they're inside or on
the boundary of the ball.
So that means the middle
bars are in the ball.
Maybe just barely, but no
matter how you move this thing--
I mean if you move this point
then the ball moves with it.
So no matter how
this thing folds,
those three bar stay
inside the ball.
What about these bars?
Or what about the endpoints?
Well if this point is
inside the ball, which
it is, and this point is
inside the ball, which it is,
then this thing is longer
than the diameter of the ball.
This thing is greater than
the sum of the middle bars.
The diameter of the ball is
So if I take any
point inside the ball
and move straight from there
by the radius of the-- more
than the diameter of the ball,
I must go outside the ball.
So the endpoints are
outside the ball.
How the heck are you
going untie that not when
all of the interior vertices
stay inside of the ball,
and these guys stay
outside the ball?
To formalize how the
heck, you can say well
if you ignore what's inside the
ball-- something's happening
there, who knows?
But outside it's
like there's a ball
and there's two sticks
coming out of it.
So you can just
imagine, for example,
tying a string
between the two ends.
And something happens
in the inside.
But if you think of just
from the outside perspective,
these sticks just move around.
It's really easy to
not tangle this cord
when these sticks move around.
So now, in order for
this thing to become
unlocked, to straighten
out for example,
somehow inside you
have to do some magic
to get rid of this topology.
Well what do I mean?
Well if you could do it inside,
you could do that motion even
when there's a
string tied out here.
But when I tie the string
out here, it is a knot.
It's a trefoil know.
There's no way to untie a
trefoil know without crossing.
So either there's
crossing in here--
which better be-- or
there's crossing out here.
There can't be
crossing out here.
It's just two
sticks and a string.
You can easily arrange
the motion of the string
to not cross the two sticks.
Therefore this thing
in fact cannot untie.
Therefore this thing is
locked, cannot straighten out.
So that's locked 3D chains.
Let me tell you a bunch
of cool open problems.
This is really the only good
example of a locked 3D chain
we have.
And it has length ratios,
the best you could do
is like 1 to 3 plus epsilon.
If each of these
is length 1, these
have to be 3 plus epsilon.
Is that the best?
Or could it be, for
example, that all the edges
or between length 1 and 2,
and the chain is locked?
We don't know.
In the extreme case, what if all
the edge lengths of the same,
all length 1?
Is there a locked 3D chain?
We now know there's
a locked 2D tree,
but for chains it's tricky.
It's even open if
you add thickness.
You say, hey, let's
think about a 3D chain,
all the edge lengths
are the same,
and you get to specify
some radius of the bars.
For a while I thought
maybe this was locked.
I don't think it is.
We can unfold.
All of these questions are
open, and pretty fascinating.
Especially because proteins
are a lot like equilateral--
like all the edge lengths
the same-- 3D chains.
It's even open for
equilateral 3D trees.
So we know 2D equilateral
trees can lock.
But 3D, it's open.
I think that's
enough open problems.
Lots of cool questions here.
All right, I have one more.
It's just fun.
Even if you have a 3D chain
where all the edges are
on top of each other
on a line segment--
it's like a linear
tree but now it's
a linear 3D chain-- it's
like a bundle of segments.
Is that locked?
I don't think so.
But even that is tricky
to come up with algorithm.
Maybe we'll work on some of
these in the problem session.
That's it.